autant en france aussi mal la géographie
que l'on apprend l'histoire ne pourriez
vous demander à gérard pas bio qui pose
son micro dans toutes les rues de france
et de navarre de tester un peu nos
concitoyens sur la question et ben
pourquoi pas madame x
c'était une idée comme les autres et je
vous invite à en suivre avec nous le
résultat le népal ça vous dit quelque
chose
ça me dit que les gens j'aurais pu
sonner je regarde parce que les gens
voir si l'on ne naît pas eux aussi sont
en bonne santé ou si son point de santé
ou s'ils sont pas en bonne santé
en suisse il y a le cervin et oui
certains oui qu'est ce que c'est ces
lettres que l'on peut déguster
directement à la cam quoi je suis le
gars était aux fournisseurs
le grand canyon du colorado vous
connaissez donc je connais pas est ce
que vous connaissez alors
on l est
désigner les verriers et volvo scania
mais le camion du colorado je connais
pas on sait par renault dès fois ci je
vous parle par exemple de l'état de
virginie
alors là je peux pas vous parler de
léthargie je ne sais pas ce qu'elle est
une femme qui est bien portante et une
femme enceinte
je ne sais pas si ça virginie je ne sais
pas je peux pas vous dire je regarde pas
l'émission l'aiguillé du midi ça vous
dit quelque chose
les deux aiguilles juste en face l'une
et l'autre pour pour faire midi le bon
blanc ça vous dit quelque chose
oui est ce que vous en pensez je pense
que c'était un produit qui peut servir
comme dessert mais à mon avis c'est ça
ne plaît pas à tout le monde parce que
c'est un peu épais le cirque de gavarnie
vous connaissez oui je connais le cirque
de gavarnie qui est très important qui
est très populaire je pense en france et
ce qu'on y trouve aussi bien que leurs
nuits des animaux du trapèze nicloux
avez vous entendu parler de l'anapurna
oui est-ce que c'est l'europe un endroit
donné est séparé de l'afrique par un
détroit
oui alors il est roi à montmagny les
etats-unis la russie et puis bon c'est
déjà les deux grandes forces c'est la
troisième je pense que c'est les
musulmans quoi les arabes
si je vous parle du côté méridional de
la suisse à quoi je pense c'est la
beauté de la mer la suisse la mer
caspienne ou ça vous dit quelque chose
c'est une mère qui cache les piafs et
d'emploi
faut-il vous vous dire vous rappelez de
cas que si ce micro trottoir n'a aucune
valeur de sondage et que toute
ressemblance avec des personnes vivant
ou ayant existé ne serait que pure
coïncidence
il n'en reste pas moins ce
micro-trottoir rigoureusement aux
antilles
[Musique]